hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today
so today let's look at set matrix zeros
we are given an m by n matrix
and we want to go through every element
if we see that an element is zero we're
gonna set the entire row
and the entire column to zero so for
example we're given
a grid there's only one zero so what are
we gonna do we're gonna set everything
in the column to zero we're gonna set
everything
in the row to zero and then we see
the output is exactly that right we got
some
zeros and then this is going to be our
output
and as you can see there's a bunch of
ways to solve this problem
with better and better complexities so
i'm gonna
show you the like bad solutions and then
show you how you can use that to get the
best solution
because it's actually pretty intuitive
so first
let's say that this is our input array
and
we declare a copy of that array
a copy of that matrix right so
then we can what we can do is go through
every position right so
the first one is a one so we don't have
to do anything then
we get a zero what does that tell us
that tells us
that the entire column is going to be
set to zero
and the row is going to be set to zero
so why can't we just do that in place
like why can't i just put a zero here
and then a zero here and now a zero here
right
because because there there's actually a
good reason because
so far we've checked off these spots we
checked off
this spot now we're over here right but
we replaced that
one with a zero now so now we're going
to end up
making this a zero and this is zero but
that's not
really what we want to do and that's the
reason why we start off with a copy
so when we make changes we're going to
make changes to
our copy and when we read the values
we're going to read from our input so
remember
we did see a zero over here so
in the copy we are gonna update
the entire row so this is gonna be a
zero
this is gonna be a zero so every value
in the row but we also have to do the
column
we see this is already a zero but this
is gonna be changed so now we made
changes to the copy so this is a zero
but we see that this is still
a one right because because now when we
go to the next position which is this we
see it's a one
so we don't actually have to modify
this column and this road
right because we haven't even read this
value yet
and now we're just gonna continue so
this is the next position
in our matrix it's a one so we don't
have to do anything
and this is the next one it's a zero so
it's time to
set the entire column to zero and set
the entire
row to zero so in our copy we
see that we actually already did this
column so
this is kind of an example of the
repeated work that we're having to do
right it kind of shows you that maybe
having a copy
is not the best solution but we still
need to update the row so we're gonna
change this to a zero
and we're gonna change this to a zero so
next we go to
this position it's a one we don't have
to do anything
and then we go to the next position this
is a zero so it's time to make some
changes
we're gonna set the entire column to
zero and we're gonna set the entire
row to zero in our copy so we see that
this is already a zero so this is the
only other value
in the output that needs to be changed
to zero
and we see that the column has already
been set to zero so clearly having a
copy
of the input array takes m by n memory
and it's also not the most time
efficient algorithm
either so how can we do better we're
noticing for
every single cell in our input we're
potentially having to update an
entire row and an entire column
can we prevent this repeated work yes
i'm going to show you how so
we see that we actually have a fixed
amount of
rows right let's call that m we have a
fixed amount
of columns n so worst case scenario
all we're gonna have to do is make sure
that every
row is set to zero and then every column
is set to zero so as we iterate
through every single value in our input
let's not update the copy we
actually don't need the copy
we need less memory we can have one
array for the number
of columns and one array for the number
of
rows and then we can mark these whether
we want to
fill in zeros or not and then at the
end we can actually fill in the zeros
in our input array without even needing
a copy
so let me show you this algorithm so we
have a one
so we don't have to do anything so this
empty indicates that we don't have to uh
zero the row or the column
next we see a zero so what are we going
to do well we're gonna
say okay in this column we're gonna fill
it
we're gonna fill it with zero so this is
some work that we have to do
in this row we are going to fill it with
zeros but we're not gonna do it yet
because we don't want to
overwrite this value that we haven't
even visited yet and we definitely don't
want to overwrite this value
yet which we haven't visited yet next we
go to this position it's a 1 so we don't
have to do anything
this is also a one this is a zero so
technically we have to mark this spot
but we already did that we already know
this column is going to be set to zero
but we want to say that this row needs
to be set to zero
we're not going to fill the zeros yet
but we're definitely gonna mark it
so this is a one we don't do anything
this is a zero
we know that this column has to be set
to zero
and this row has to be set
to zero now technically we see that
every row is gonna be set to zero so
so therefore like the entire matrix is
just gonna be zero but
we're still gonna continue our algorithm
so this is a one we don't have to do
anything
this is a one we don't have to do
anything so now what we're gonna do
is we're gonna look at this memory and
it's gonna tell us which columns need to
be set to zero so we see the first
column does need to be set to zero
we're gonna do that the second column
needs to be set to zero
we're gonna do that the third column
does not need to be set to zero
next we look at the rows the first row
needs to be set to zero we mostly
already did that but
don't forget about this one the second
row is going to be set to zero
the third row is going to be set to zero
and obviously the entire matrix is now
zero but
the advantage of this is the memory we
used
we didn't need to create an entire copy
we just needed
two arrays so the memory complexity is
actually
big o m plus n where these are the
dimensions
the time complexity is m
by n because we're really just iterating
over the entire matrix
at most three times one where we iterate
through every position
one where we fill in the columns and
another time where we fill in the rows
and i didn't tell you the time
complexity of this one but it is
actually greater than the time
complexity
of this so this is actually a better
time
solution and a better memory solution
now my only
question is can we get a o of
one memory solution we know the time
the best time complexity we can do is m
by n because we do
have to iterate through every single
position in
the matrix but we can save some space
is it possible yes i'm going to show you
how
is there a way where we can take this
array
and put it into the matrix so we're we
can do this in
place is that possible if i put that
over here is it possible for
us to take this uh array
and put it in to
our matrix the answer is yes we can take
these two arrays that we have and put
them
in our matrix so we do this in place
with
o of one memory but you see just one
problem
right just one little problem notice
how this position is overlapping the two
arrays are overlapping in this position
so we
we do need a tiny bit more memory we
just need
one more uh cell right we just need one
more
variable but we know that that's still
big o
of one so i'm actually for the purple
one which tells us which rows we need to
zero i'm going to
have it be one less we don't want them
to overlap
so we can get rid of this we don't
actually need the extra memory
from these input arrays we don't need
this extra memory but we do need this
one
single last cell because we see that
there's no room for it over here the
green one
took that from us so you can see this is
big o
of one memory right we're just using one
extra cell that's constant memory
and so this is going to tell us whether
we need to zero out the first
row or not so now we're just going to
run through
the matrix for the third and last time
so this is a one we don't have to do
anything
this is a zero so what are we gonna do
we're gonna mark
this cell and how are we gonna mark it
well we're gonna set
this to zero which it already is right
and we're gonna set this to zero
indicating that this
row needs to be zeroed out this
zero tells us that this column needs to
be zeroed out
next we go to this cell it's a one great
we don't have to do anything
this is a one great we don't have to do
anything this is a zero
so what are we gonna do well we're gonna
set
this cell to zero to indicate that this
column needs to be zeroed out but it's
already zero good for
us but we also need to set
this to zero to tell us that this
row needs to be zeroed out and you see
why this solution works right so now
we're gonna set this to zero
and that's okay for us because we
already
visited that cell we already saw that it
initially had a one
so we can overwrite it we're allowed to
do that
the reason this works is we start at the
top
left over here and then work our way
down right we start here
and work our way top to bottom left
to right so now we visit this cell it's
a one
nothing to do we visit this zero so we
got
we got some work to do we need to set
this top value to zero to indicate that
this column needs to be zeroed out
and we need to set this position to zero
to indicate that the row needs to be
zeroed out but it's already zero
which is good for us so now we get a one
nothing to do we get another one nothing
to do
okay so now that we know we know which
rows
we need to zero out and we know which
columns we have to zero out so all we
have to do is fill in those zeros
so we start we start here we know this
entire
column needs to be zero it already is we
know this column needs to be zero it
mostly is we just have to change this
last value
this is a one so we don't have to zero
out this column
next let's go through the rows so this
row needs to be zeroed out so we can
change this
to a zero this row needs to be zeroed
out
so we can change this to a zero the
third row
also needs to be zeroed out so we can
change
this to a zero now the entire thing is
zero which is the result that we
expected
but the good thing about the solution is
we did it
in place all we really needed was one
extra variable so with all that being
said let's
finally write the big o of
one memory solution so the first thing
i'm just gonna do is
get the number of rows and columns and
put them in some variables so we don't
have to
keep computing that we can get the
length of the matrix and get the length
of the first
row of the matrix which tells us the
number of columns
remember we don't need extra arrays but
we just
need one extra variable to tell us if
the first row is
zero or not so initially i'm going to
set this
to false to say that the first row is
not zero but we'll
update it to true if we need to so
remember that the first thing we want to
know is
determine which rows and columns
need to be zeroed so we can
iterate through every position in our
cell
so we're gonna go through every row and
we're gonna go through
every column if we ever find a
value that is zeros in this case
what we so if we find a zero what are we
gonna do we're gonna
set the first row so row
zero in this column we're going to set
that value
to zero what we also want to do is
in the first column so
column is zero we want to set that
row position to zero as well
but just one catch we cannot set that
for the top leftmost position so
only we're only gonna do this if row
is greater than zero because remember
for row 0 we
actually have a dedicated value so
if rho 0 is greater than 0 then we do
this
but otherwise we're going to actually
update
this value our boolean so
we're going to set that to true and so
that's
it we're just marking which rows and
columns to zero
out so now the way i'm actually going to
zero them out is going to be a little
bit different than how i showed in the
picture i'm actually gonna go through
every position one more time
so every uh row column pair and i'm
gonna check
for each position so for this row column
pair is
the do we need to zero it out and how do
we know if we're gonna zero it out
well see up here we would set the first
row to zero so if
the first row value is zero that means
that we're going to zero this out but
also
if the column is zero so if
matrix of the first column
of this row is equal to zero
then in either of these cases we wanna
set
the current position that we're at to
zero
and so we cannot actually just do this
by iterating through every row column
we have to actually skip the first row
and we have to skip the first column
because we're gonna handle that after so
now that we zeroed out
the main part of our matrix we can
potentially
zero out the first row and the first
column if we need to so
for we're gonna check if the
origin of our matrix is zero
so remember the first row of the matrix
tells us
which columns we can zero out so if this
is equal to zero that means we can set
every
value we can set every value
in our matrix in the first column
so i'm gonna say column is zero
so if the first column in the first row
is zero
then every value so what we're doing
here is basically zeroing out the first
column of our matrix and
last but not least we have to take a
look at
our last uh variable that we declared so
row zero this tells us if we're going to
zero out the first
row so if row zero is true
meaning we have to zero out the first
row we're gonna go through every
value in the first row
and zero it out so matrix of the first
row
row index zero and every position in
that row
we're gonna zero it out so that's the
algorithm
first we've determined which rows and
columns to zero out
then we zero out most of them
then we zero out the first column
if we need to and lastly we zero out the
first
row if we need to and we don't have to
return anything
because we did this in place which is
what the problem wanted us to do
okay i'm so dumb i don't know why i
didn't finish this line of code don't
forget to
put this to zero